pretty much nobody would mind if Togashi
kept writing the story while another
artist would take care of the art
tagashi art is really secondary to his
writing I agree I mean I mean I'm sure
that somebody would mind but I think
that most of us would be pretty okay
with this there are certain manga series
where I think that art and story are
inseparable one piece for example the
author echura Oda basically makes up a
story according to what he wants to draw
so if he thinks of a cool silhouette and
he'll write a dramatic character
introduction and if he thinks of say an
action composition then he will write a
fight just to draw that panel Hunter
Hunter is kind of the opposite tagashi
draws more as a mechanism to get his
story out but I don't think that the art
itself is his passion if we're being
honest manga is a bit of a love-hate
medium for Mr Togashi in the past he has
stated a distaste for almost all
components among production with the
exception of story I would not complain
at all if Hunter Hunter got another
artist who could mimic tagashi's style
in fact I wouldn't even complain if
tagashi just decided to novelize the
rest of Hunter Hunter I know it's a
classic joke that reading Hunter Hunter
is like reading a novel anyway but that
aside I would be legitimate excited to
read a real succession War novel with
that said the most Ideal World is to let
Togashi tell his own story on his own
terms and if he wants to draw it himself
then that that's the thing it is that
he's gonna do so let's have some more
controversial opinions tagashi's art is
really good is this controversial I mean
I guess it is most artists highly
subjective but hunter hunter in
particular occupies a very weird space
with art and I'm not even talking about
the latter half of the series where
togashi's condition heavily impacted his
drawing I mean from the very get-go it's
a Love or hate art style it's very and I
don't mean this in a negative way but
it's very simplistic very evocative of a
lot of 70s and Aegis type manga which
makes sense that would have been
tagashi's influence and there's a lot I
like about it the clean flat style does
make things very easy to follow and
digest because rarely is something drawn
on page that isn't 100 necessary the
things I don't like about the visuals
are less to do with the art itself per
se and more how tagashi uses his art to
convey certain things like say time
passing or location changer so for
example at the beginning of the chimera
antarcton kilowatt and kite travel
across the world between chapters it
just happens like that you finish one
chapter you pick up the next one they're
there and tagashi doesn't give you any
visual assistance in depicting this time
passing it just happens and may that
that's a lot of time that just happens
and a whole new location that we're
supposed to be in that you may miss and
yeah I get it you don't need to show
every step of the journey but I think
some connective tissue is helpful in a
series as dances Hunter Hunter maybe
even just an opening singular panel of a
plane having landed because I think
things can get unnecessarily confusing
due to the lack of a clear sense of time
and location here's something fun though
tagashi very often uses his
quote-unquote bad art to his Advantage
one panel that really struck me was
during the hunter exam where kilowa was
confronting illumi and the way Togashi
drew the background was very wavy and
sketchy but not in a hyper-stylized Way
Beyond itself is more like someone who
had never picked up a pen was trying to
draw the background which perfectly fits
the scene because it's showing killer
was world breaking down the firm's solid
masterful lines are now devolving into a
child trying to draw their first comic
which really really hit home how young
killer is and just how much he's at the
mercy of Illinois however with that said
if you'd shown me that panel out of
context and I probably would have called
it objectively bad art gen through was a
much more talented nen user than people
give him credit for so this was a very
popular unpopular opinion which means
I'm not even sure if it's actually a
controversial opinion anymore but
genthru was very impressive when you
think about what he did countdown
utilizes three different net affinities
emission manipulation and gen through's
natural conjuration that's very
impressive because emission is the
weakest Divinity for contrast a
manipulation isn't exactly the
friendliest diet although I do think
this turns into a discussion of talent
vs desire ganthru's desire to blow the
crap out of people in the most sadistic
way possible was so strong that he
pushed Beyond his limits and tapped into
affinities that logically he has no
business using oh and because this is
Gen through I will never not bring this
up but one of the countdown bombs is
seen very suspiciously On this man's
crotch which means again through must
have touched it to plant the bomb so
they must have had a very interesting
and probably very heated discussion
imagine being that guy the bomb appears
on your junk and everyone just looks at
you like dude what what were you doing
Kikyo zoldik is super underrated she
adds so much to the family Dynamics and
an overall character of the zoldx with
only small amounts of screen time kikio
definitely doesn't get enough
appreciation quite specifically from the
actual author of the series kikio feels
like a very neglected character what
fascinates me about Kikyo is the fact
that she's from meteor City so the
zoldik family probably have a process of
incorporating how shall we say birthing
Partners into the family business but
also kikio has one of the most
intriguing visual design with her Vice
which weirdly enough kind of evolves
backwards in flashbacks Kikyo has this
very sleek and modern visor however in
the actual modern day she wears this
clunky VR looking headset that
encompasses her whole head and I just
think that's an interesting historical
footner tagashi first Drew Kikyo in the
90s when Tech was very clunky and
awkward in their phones were bricks but
by the time he drew this flashback we
were in 2011 maybe even 2012 and Tech
had become much more Sleek the brick
phones had turned into like funky
iPhones so so as a result past Kikyo who
was drawn in the future gets a more
modern device whereas modern Kikyo drawn
in the past gets a clunky piece of tech
also kikio has one of the weirdest
romanized names being and I don't think
I'm going to pronounce this correctly
and I'm honestly convinced that whoever
wrote that accidentally lent on the
keiki a bit too long and they just left
it but now Mo's old dick opinions illumi
had a much worse life than killer being
the oldest illumi was most likely used
as a test subject for training
techniques and was also trained by the
adults kikio Zeno and Silva so basically
whatever he did to kilwa he probably had
done to him 10 times worse this is
interesting because I think it could go
both ways as the firstborn ilumi was
likely honed in on a bit more intensely
there was probably a lot of pressure to
get him right so to speak whatever right
is for a family of Assassins I mean
there are times when I look into
illumi's cold dead eyes and I wonder if
he was born that way or if this is the
result of him just being broken as a
human and maybe they were even a bit
Reckless with illumi you know the whole
if we fail with illumin then now we'll
just keep popping out spawn until we get
one of them right but then again
kilowatt is recognized as the most
naturally talented of his siblings so he
also could have been trained with an
even higher degree of scrutiny and of
course kilowa was partially raised by
illumi as well and whether that made his
situation better or worse is almost
impossible to tell I say almost it's
definitely impossible to tell illumi
genuinely cares for kilowatts so that
may have made him a bit softer or it
might have made him a lot harsher with
the whole idea of but this is for the
good of my brother and all that tough
love tough zodic torturous assassin love
the gone vs moral fight is one of the
best in the show in terms of
foreshadowing and plot I guess this
really doesn't get talked about a lot
because well it really isn't a fight but
it does lay some very important
foundation this is the precursor for
gone losing himself with Pito because he
does the same thing here with Moro when
moral asks gone to pretend that he was
the one who killed kite that was a
potentially life-ending mistake because
gone was not in control of the situation
and he may very well have killed moral
if kilowa had not stepped in to bring
him back it stresses that kilowatt is
really the only thing retaining God's
Humanity at this point so when gone
ultimately does cast killer aside during
the palace Invasion that's when we know
that gone is going to some serious Dark
Places because that final barrier is no
longer there gonze angst in the Chimera
antarct was wasted from kite being
reincarnated and would have been better
if he stayed dead as it honestly feels
very unlikely we'll ever see him her
again you know many many many years
later I'm still not sure how I feel
about this to be honest because I
generally hate hate hate bringing
characters back to life as an author if
you choose to kill a character then I as
a reader respects that however if you
then bring the character back then it
makes me think that you think you've
made a mistake it breaks the emotion
because it feels like the narrative
equivalent of hitting the undo button
you killed a character and later on
think ha oh no maybe I shouldn't have
done that just don't don't bring them
back just leave them dead Let the dead
rest with that said I do think kite's
situation is a bit different though
because the Chimera and talk as a whole
has this idea of identity which it tends
to explore through reincarnation the
ideas of all humans still the same
people after having been reborn as ants
can they reclaim their Humanity which
they actually tend to most of the ants
become emotional sympathetic characters
like your cowgos and your melioronons
meliorons the chameleon whereas a lot of
the humans tend to actually devolve into
the instinctual monsters so adding kite
back into the mix is just another layer
for that idea if I had to guess and this
would be a very optimistic guess I would
say that kite may have been intended to
act as a counter-balance to Gyra a
strong nen using protagonist who can
flourish with Newfound antibilities but
the problem with that is that it banks
on kite being used in the future which
just like the controversial opinion
holder I'm not sure him or her will be
and I know that some people also argue
that kite being resurrected took
something away from God the idea that he
no longer has to deal with the results
of his actions because hey everything
turned out pretty okay kite's alive
despite the brutal murder but I honestly
don't care too much about that because
it all just brings Gone full circle he
starts the series is pretty much exactly
where he ends as a relatively innocent
non-nen-using child but having gained
the knowledge of who his father is in
the end kite living doesn't offend me in
the same way that a lot of authors
bringing back characters does the shadow
beasts weren't bad nen users they were
just overconfident and unprepared you
know I would argue that being both
overconfident and unprepared is exactly
what makes you a bad non-user like
forget all of the actual underwhelming
abilities like a worm dude and Mr spiky
hair and the guy that guy the guy who
used nen to put sacks of leeches in his
body that guy forget forget all of that
for a second because as an end user you
have two options if you're going to walk
into a fight unprepared then you
practically need to have a doctorate
level of understanding of nen combat so
that you can quickly analyze and adapt
to any situation presented so either
that or you don't get into the fight to
begin with and the shadow beasts were
the worst of Both Worlds they had
minimal understanding of nen probably
thought that they knew a lot more than
they did potentially victims of the
dunning-kruger effect I suppose and they
failed abysmal only as a result it's a
very rare person who can just stroll
internet combat without any knowledge
for the opponent you would need to be
either a karapika level genius or a
hisoka level instinctual improviser
Hunter should have ended when gon found
his father you know tagashi himself
actually kind of agrees with that
because there's a famous interview where
he said I do intend to finish it
although you can say that at one point
in the story where God meets Jing I have
completed the story once as a jump
reader myself I also remember having
thought shouldn't this manga have just
ended here so tagashi actually confused
himself with his own story and a world
probably could have existed where he did
and Hunt Hunter there but continued the
story of the world in a sequel series
starring karapika or Jing or whoever
which is essentially what happened
anyway but it's also worth noting that
tagashi went on to say but hunter hunter
as it is now has a lot in it that makes
me want to keep on reading even from my
own perspective as a reader and from my
perspective as a writer there are still
many things in it left that I want to
write that I would enjoy writing and so
if anyone would be willing to enjoy this
ride with me I that is all I can hope
for basically he still has a passion for
the series a passion for quite
specifically writing the series and
contrary to popular belief he is
probably far more grateful to fans who
continue to read at this point than many
other mangaka but what's your
controversial Hunter Hunter opinion let
me know in the comments or don't and go
watch another video instead or do
whatever it is that you do with your day